at seven o'clock I'm Dermot mernahan
this is Sky News Tonight live from
Downing Street where in a little over a
week a new prime minister will be moving
into the building behind me
I cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
let's trust steps down becoming the
shortest serving prime minister in
British history after just six weeks in
office
that will be possible to conduct a
ballot and conclude a leadership
election
by Friday the 28th of October
the chairman of the 1922 committee sir
Graham Brady fires the starting gun on
the Sprint to become her successor
among the hopefuls her predecessor Boris
Johnson is also expected to stand but
later say it's time to give the people a
say
this should be a general election we
can't just allow the Tory party to keep
putting up the next candidate in the
middle of this chaos
[Music]
a very good evening from Downing Street
on yet another remarkable day after just
44 days as prime minister Liz truss has
resigned the shortest Premiership in
British history a visit this morning by
the chairman of the powerful 1922
committee Was Then followed by a 92nd
resignation speech the Prime Minister
claimed that given the situation she
could not deliver on her mandate and
therefore in just over a week's time the
building behind me will have a new
residence coming up we'll tell you the
rules that have been announced to find
that person see who the hopefuls are and
look back on Liz trusses rise and fall
but first here's our political editor
Beth Rigby
it is over the shortest serving prime
minister stepping down
I came into office at a time of great
economic and international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
a mandate which slipped away after just
six weeks
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party I
have therefore spoken to his majesty the
king to notify him that I am resigning
as leader of the conservative party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
turning her back on an embattled
Premiership only her husband by her side
this a very lonely way to leave
so gray and Brady the man charged with
the next steps yeah police agree I'm
here please Instagram setting out the
direction of the party and Country too
I have spoken to the party chairman Jake
Berry and he has confirmed that it will
be possible to conduct a ballot and
conclude a leadership election
by Friday the 28th of October so we
should have a new leader in place before
the fiscal statement which will take
place on the 31st a new leadership
contest the second in four months
conducted at Breakneck speed this time
next week we'll have a new PM for the
press and the public too it's
bewildering how disappointed are you in
this the public must be looking at this
thinking what on Earth is going on this
is the governing party absolutely and I
think we're deeply conscious of the
imperative and the national interest of
resolving this clearly and quickly
by early evening the detail coming to
light conservative MPS have to decide
fast uh good afternoon again uh just to
confirm I've met with the board of the
conservative party and the executive of
the United 22 commission the process for
the Parliamentary stages of the contest
will begin now nominations are now open
uh we'll close at two o'clock on Monday
candidates will be expected to have at
least 100
colleagues nominating them
a decision to whittle the field back
dramatically if only one MP hits the
threshold we'll know the new PM by
Monday this will be quick but for labor
it's not enough it's demanding a general
election saki you're calling for a
general election but at a moment of
acute instability there has been Market
instability there's a cost of living
crisis the Tories are going to replace
the Prime Minister within a week
in the general election is going to take
weeks and weeks and weeks can you see
that that might not be practical right
now but the risk to the country is
carrying on with this utter chaos so
you've got this real Choice utter chaos
with the conservatives or stability
under a labor government so the risk is
not a general election the risk is
carrying on with this utter chaos
they've made huge they've damaged the
economy very badly in the last few weeks
this damage has been done
the conservative parties decided we need
a new prime minister Liz truss has been
forced to resign after just 44 days in
office this whole sorry Affair has been
a dark dark chapter for the Tories MPS
are now trying to turn the corner there
will be a new prime minister next week
but the party is having in the words of
one Minister a collective breakdown and
after two lots of vicious blood let him
fast around Boris Johnson and now around
Liz truss you have to ask yourself
whether a new leader can stop the rot
sun set in on a deeply unsettling day in
Westminster in these tumultuous times a
nation awaiting leadership Beth Rigby
Sky News Westminster
well of course just last month Liz trust
ended number 10 after a leadership
campaign that lasted eight weeks she was
finally installed as leader and prime
minister after about 81 000 Tory members
voted for her now this time round that
process is being distilled down to just
one week let's take a look at how that
is proposed to work so sir Graham Brady
the chair of the 1922 announced that
nominations for the race to be the next
prime minister are now open they will
close at 2PM on Monday that's for MPS
candidates will need at least 100
nominations from conservative MPS to
meet the threshold if there is more than
one candidate that meets those
requirements and online vote for
conservative party members will then
open and all stages they say of the
leadership election are intended to be
concluded by next Friday the 28th of
October now in terms of who may stand
well currently Rishi sunak is the
bookmaker's favorite to take over of
course the defeated candidate last time
round followed by Penny mordant then
well get this Boris Johnson appears to
be the third most popular the former
prime minister then the defense
secretary Ben Wallace kemi badinoff
could also be running as well perhaps as
the foreign secretary James cleverley
and maybe the just resigned Home
Secretary swella bravaman Michael Gove
Tom tugenhout and Jeremy Hunt are
amongst those unlikely to take part
after ruling themselves out of the race
our Deputy political editor Sam Coates
reports
just 111 days ago Boris Johnson came out
of the door of number 10 and told the
nation that he was stepping down
it was the end of a long struggle to
stay in office but for him it was never
over a hint in his last speech to the
commons that he would be back
I want to thank everybody here and
hasta la vista baby thank you
the former prime minister now looms over
the race to be the next PM this a party
in desperate need of a savior
some see the man who secured what is
still a 71-seat majority as the only
hope what we need now we need someone
who can come in we need someone who can
bring people together somebody who
actually has got that mandate so a
mandate from the people at the last
general election a mandate from party
members and somebody actually who can
get this party going again get us
winning elections again the only person
that I think that ticks all those boxes
is Boris Johnson
but the issues that nearly forced him
out of office and nearly split his party
in two still remain the trust
Premiership too short to allow them to
fully heal
God was part of Team Boris I was
disappointed to see him go but I I think
it's probably too soon I think that's
probably wishful thinking from some of
my colleagues on that front why do you
say XTC I just I just think it's too
soon that the the I was there supporting
him to the very end but he did lose the
confidence of the majority of our
colleagues I thought that was wrong but
you have to respect that this man
believes he's the one to fix the crisis
no answer to that question this morning
his supporters suggest it could come
soon however MP's favorite last time
round but he made many enemies along the
way what you need to do is have a broad
group of people supporting you a broad
group of people coming into government
bringing the party together and I think
Rishi with who got support from right
across the country got the most MP
support last time is a person to do that
now because we have to have that unity
and also competence and economic
leadership right at the top
Penny Morton faced down the opposition
on Liz truss's behalf earlier this week
for many it looked like an audition for
the top job her allies say she's the
only one to unite a fractured party
um I think she has a great set of
qualities she has lots of ministerial
experience I think she comes across very
well and I think she resonates with
people and right now when we are facing
a couple of international crises both in
energy but also in the Ukraine war
having somebody with stature with
government experience and who can
resonate with people I think is really
important Boris Johnson is doing what he
always does dominating the conversation
pushing everyone else to the margins now
today's Tory leadership rules look
awfully like an attempt to stop him
returning to high office but he smashed
through obstacles before and that's why
some Tory MPS want to keep him away from
the Tory membership where he remains a
firm favorite
plenty of others eyeing a run but new
chances that Jeremy Hunt says he's
staying out for the rest a bruising few
days ahead it could be over sooner than
next Friday if contenders drop out and
deny the members a vote
but warnings this would damage the party
further if members of parliament Rob for
membership of their constitutional right
by our rules to choose who is the leader
of the party that will probably cause a
lot of upset it'll probably mean very
few of us have any activists come the
next general election and the party will
fall into a very very low place he
divided his party as prime minister some
think he can now unite the party again
will enough MPS try and stop Boris
Johnson this time Sam Coates Sky News
Westminster
well our political editor Beth Rick B is
here with me in Downing Street and Beth
we keep saying this don't worry about
the extraordinary 24 hours that is just
passed but just address for us the
process that finally got Liz truss to
address reality it all really started to
unravel finally last night it did and
and I was on the television last night
and I was saying
it's clear that she's going to have to
go the question is the speed
and as these things sometimes go the
speed was fast this morning you remember
when Boris Johnson resigned he went when
the herd moves it moves and it moved it
stampeded her this morning look what
happened overnight was that more letters
or went in more MPS publicly said that
they couldn't back her then what
happened was Sir Graham Brady he's the
guy that is the shop manager if you like
of all of the conservative MPS he went
in to see the prime minister of source
at the time said that the Prime Minister
had asked to seem that she wanted to
take the temperature of the party he was
soon followed in there by Therese coffee
the Deputy Prime Minister and Liz
truss's most trusted Ally and then Jake
Barry the chairman of the conservative
party and at that point you're wondering
well if Jake Berry is in there is this
now something about regime change we
then got very short notice about a
statement at 1 30 ran down here yeah and
I was told by a source a few minutes
before that she was going to resign as
my source said to me it's over it's over
for her and then she came out 90 seconds
wasn't it she spoke for very short
statement let's move on then to to the
battle the
contest to replace sir now we were told
during this kind of drawn out process
that they may be looking to have a
coronation to choose an agreed candidate
clearly they haven't been able to do
that and so we are going to get it's
going to be foreshorten but we're going
to get eight days of drift again
we are potentially not going to have
eight days of drift diamond and the
reason I say that is the way they have
structured the contest is they've set
the threshold for the number of MPS that
you have to get to support you extremely
high I was told earlier in the week that
they were looking at maybe 100 to 120
MPS some people didn't think that they
would set the bar quite that high
because they argued the Parliamentary
party wouldn't want to feel it was to
quote this senior conservative as Stitch
up for one individual candidate but so
Graham Brady when he was explained the
rules said to us earlier he thought up
to three people could potentially get
the nomination so 357 MPS to give you a
bit of context of where we are Rishi
sunat got 137 backers in the round the
first contest where Liz truss went on to
win Penny Morden got 105 so you could
see a scenario where Rishi sunak and
penny more didn't get through that just
about leaves enough about Johnson Boris
Johnson uh has a number of backers there
are doubts that he can get to that
figure of a hundred from MPS and also
kirstan when I interviewed earlier today
uh had all the attack lines ready of MPS
ousting him to then uh bring him back
into power it could be quite a leap
couldn't it for the party but the reason
I say
it could be a coronation and don't I
don't know
is that if only one candidate gets over
the line by 2PM on Monday that person is
effectively the prime minister so at the
latest we'll have a new prime minister
by Friday a week tomorrow and at the
earliest we could have someone so just
in case they're not going to whittle
them down so if one person gets over 100
I mean that therefore means the more
that stand the more chance one person
has of getting through
you have to have over a hundred
nominations to go into it if you have
three then yes there'll be a runoff
between the three of them what's really
interesting though German and this is
what MPS will say me telling me they
wanted and what's different from last
time is that sir Graham has said there
will be an indicative vote now why does
that matter because MP's last time
wanted Rishi sunak he was the first
choice members went for Liz truss so in
this scenario what the party is now
doing the Parliamentary party is saying
if we put this out to members if there
isn't one only one candidate for an
online ballot ahead of Friday
MPS want to sing signal to members who
is their choice and they hope I guess
that that will influence members votes
the question is if the question is if
there's two candidates in the preferred
candidate
of MPS doesn't win
what situation are we then and I I think
the big pitch in all of this Dharma as I
said in that piece to camera this party
is so Riven with grievances with
bitterness with division whoever takes
over
it's going to be one hell of a job to
bring the conservative party back
together
let's leave that as your final thought
for the moments see you again soon Beth
because I want to test the temperature
within the party within sections of the
parties best referring to because
someone speak now to John Lamont a
conservative MP supporting penny mordant
so well very good to talk to Mr Lamont
do you think she will get a hundred then
to get into the the final running well I
know penny is um speaking to um
colleagues this evening and she's been
overwhelmed by the number of colleagues
number of MPS who have spoken to her who
have indicated that we like her um to
stand and I I certainly hope that she
does stand up actor back in the summer
when there was a leadership election
after Boris had um resigned and I and I
hope she put puts herself um forward
again I'll certainly enthusiastically
back or if that's what she decides to do
is it a strength that she's served
loyally and Liz truss's cabinets are
presumably signed off on the disastrous
mini budget
well I think it's important that we um
look forward and learn the lessons um
from the mistakes that are made over the
last month month or so I believe penny
is the candidate that you can bring not
just the the party together
um in terms of the cabinet and also the
wider um part of it of MPS but she can
bring the the country together and reach
into parts of the electorate and which I
think will perhaps not connected with in
the best way that we might might have
done so I think penny has great voter
appeal and if we're trying to get
ourselves back back in in into an
improved position compared to where we
are just now in the opinion pools I
think the penny is a person to do that
so she would unite the party and unite
the country
but would you I mean can we be assured
that she's rid herself with the idea
that Liz trusts his original policies
were a good idea
well those were policies of um less
trust and um clearly she has ignored her
cabinet she made mistakes and the cabin
has acknowledged that mistakes have have
been made and we now need to move
forward I I believe penny has has the
skills in terms of taking on labor
taking on the samp beautiful refresh
mandate fresh ideas and crucially I
think bringing all talent in into her
cabinet she's been very very clear I
think during the last contest that she
would run a very inclusive cabinet
bringing people in from all parts of the
party and all talent and that's that I
think is what the Parliamentary party
wants and that's what the country
expects
and in terms of the talent in the next
cabinet is it a given that the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt has to remain the
chancellor he's the man who has calmed
the markets he's the man who's working
on this all-important statement on
October the 31st just three days
potentially after the new prime minister
is installed he has to stay whoever wins
doesn't he well clearly that's a matter
for whoever whoever wins this contest
and the matter for Penny if she became
prime minister if she decides to uh
stand but I think you're right Jeremy
Hunters on an incredible job over the
last few days just settling things down
coming and now it's reassuring the city
and and hopefully the new government
knew the new prime minister will be able
to continue that and certainly as I said
I'm not going to second guess what the
new prime minister would do but I don't
I don't dispute your assertion that
Jeremy has done a very good good job of
the last few days
but on that basis given we're all
watching the money markets the bond
markets they almost have a vote in this
wouldn't it be better to have in effect
two chancellors in there and I'm talking
about Rishi sunak either as prime
minister or perhaps as Chancellor under
Jeremy Hunt if you want reassurance in
the bond markets certainly do they would
give it
well why hope is Rivers is prime
minister and all those names will be in
the cabinet and serving the Prime
Minister and serving
um the country I think one of the
criticisms of Liz trustee's um
Administration was there wasn't a broad
enough Church within her cabinet I would
hope that whoever takes over and I
obviously hope that Penny will stand and
Penny will be successful she will bring
all these people in to ensure that we
are not just reassuring the city but
reassuring The Wider electorate that we
know what we're doing we're able to run
the economy and we're able to run the um
country because I think people have you
know be a bit unsettled it's fair to say
over the last few um weeks and months
and they want reassurance that we're
moving forward I think penny has the
skills to do that John I'm not very good
talking to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us on Sky News
tonight
and you are watching Sky News Tonight a
special Live program from Downing Street
coming up we'll be speaking to the
former education secretary Justine
Greening
[Music]
minutes and now it's coming from both
sides
it's moving this way
[Music]
only about half a mile from the Turkish
coast and it's evident that there's been
both seriously overcrowded this is one
of the most severe viruses in the world
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
has
it it got us then a lot of action going
on
a lot of people still
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
[Music]
look at her arms I can put my entire
hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain World
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
the world just Falls now down to a
chapel in places
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake whoa
[Music]
close and personal with Iran
this is what makes the job
foreign
[Music]
Street where Liz truss resigned as prime
minister this afternoon the battle is
now well underway to replace so there
will be a new prime minister in place by
next Friday the 28th let's talk now then
to the former education secretary and
former conservative MB of course Justine
Greening very good to see you Justine
Greening well first of all do you think
Liz trust did the right thing
I think it was inevitable so yes I do
and I think the big mistake that she
made was thinking that she could simply
leave behind the Mandate that the
conservative party won at the last
election which was to drive a leveled up
Britain people wanted skills and talent
and it caused the opportunity not tax
cuts
and so she's fallen on her sword uh
having sacked the chancellor so the
architects of that process now gone who
should replace uh I mean I put the point
earlier to a penny Morden set supporter
that perhaps anyone who was in that
cabinet should not be really suitable
for the job
I think the question is is almost as
much what that next prime minister is
there to do as as much as it is who the
reality is people have been very clear
what they wanted from this conservative
Administration when they voted for it at
the last election this is a leadership
contest to sort out who is going to be
best place to deliver that agenda of
leveling up and and I think what the
party needs to realize and remember is
that leveling up is the growth strategy
for Britain there are businesses around
this country who cannot get the skills
that they need that's what's hindering
growth and so really this is going to be
a contest about who can deliver that the
best what an incoming prime minister
does not get to do is to totally
reinvent their own mandate and Liz
truss's big mistake alongside
quasi-protang was to shift away from
leveling up and suddenly think that they
could do whatever they wanted that's not
how the British democracy works and if a
new conservative Administration coming
in fails to learn that lesson then they
will probably go down the same route
that Liz truss's Administration has just
done
and what the next prime minister has to
do is realize that they simply can't
invent any money it's all gone there's
nothing left to spend it's all about
filling in black holes is there a case
you talk about leveling up but is there
a case for saying the next
Administration will be well more like
the one you served in that there has to
be a dollop of austerity
well there are going to clearly be some
difficult choices about how you balance
the books but what the markets want to
see is a long-term economic plan for
Britain and the reality is it's lives
that are off track that cost the
taxpayer money not lives that are on
track and contributing and in work and
paying tax so leveling up isn't just
about being a fairer Society it is the
economic strategy for Britain increasing
productivity demo is about improving per
capita GDP growth it's about people we
now have to understand that in the same
way we talk about long-term investment
in physical infrastructure whether it's
roads Railways we have to have a
long-term investment in our human
capital people so that they can be the
growth driver if you like of the the
economy long term and I think that's
what the markets want to see they want
to see that long-term plan what I want
to see from those people who are now
seeking to replace those trusts is how
do they plan to drive level but a
leveled up rent how are they going to
put that long-term plan in place to
finally deliver a quality of opportunity
because that's what the British people
were voting for and actually in terms of
how you bring the conservative
parliamentary parties together it's
leveling up that is that Common Thread
that I think all MPS and conservative
party can get behind
Justine Greening great to get your
thoughts as always thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you
when I'm discussing the markets uh there
was positive Market reaction in the
moments after Liz truss announced her
resignation it was her radical economic
plan as we've just been discussing and
the subsequent humiliating climb Downs
that sent those shock waves through the
economy our data and economics editor Ed
Conway has been looking at that reaction
at the Sky News Center
perhaps the best place to start actually
is looking back all the way well not
really very far 44 days six weeks of
what's happened in the pound versus the
dollar because never really have we had
a prime minister ship which has been so
defined by what's happened in markets
for the entirety of those indeed six
weeks and it's worth just running
through it this is the pound against the
US dollar there's been various other
chance we've been looking at recently in
particular Government Bond rates but
this also tells you quite a lot because
the higher that is the stronger the
pound is the lower it is the weaker the
pound is you can see the moment that
list trust came in and just look at this
line as it continues through September
you had obviously the mini budget now
notorious and look at what happened to
Sterling after that weakening weakening
weakening weakening getting down to
the lowest level that it's ever ever got
to against the US dollar only a few
weeks ago now and then gradually
recovering as the bank of England
intervened and of course later on
quasiquartang uh getting fired and you
can see the pound getting stronger there
and indeed all the way up to where we
are now with little trust resigning the
pound strengthened again not by all that
much frankly compared with the enormous
roller coaster that we've had since but
what this underlines is the extent to
which first this has been defined by
charts like this and secondly any future
leadership contest is likely to be
defined as well by what happens in
markets because we're in an
extraordinary moment now with a new
chancellor who can expect potentially
that he might be able to hold on to that
place if only because people are so
nervous about what's happening in
financial markets we've never seen a
prime minister ship quite like this one
both in terms of the policy in terms of
the length and in terms of the
concentration of what financial markets
think about the UK
accommodate with the analysis and Joe
watching Sky News Tonight coming up
we'll get some of the international
reaction to today's resignation with a
former U.S ambassador to the United
Kingdom
[Music]
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Downing Street let's
look now at some of the international
reaction to the prime minister's
resignation namely out of the United
States and this was President Joe Biden
speaking as he left the White House a
bit earlier
she was a good partner on Russia and
Ukraine and uh and the British are going
to solve their problem and but she was a
good partner
president but reference to the UK's
problems well let's speak now to Matthew
barzan the former United States
ambassador to the United Kingdom of
course knows this country very well and
and could I just get you to reflect and
very good to talk to you Ambassador just
to reflect on in the what the five years
or so since you left four Prime
Ministers do you recognize this country
anymore
uh good to be with you again thanks for
having me on no I I do recognize it of
course
um there have been
four Prime Ministers leaving in that
amount of time there's been one
political party in power that whole time
so there's been change Within
a party that's remained the same
um the thing I've been focusing on and
answering questions from Americans who
like me are big admirers of your country
is that so often if we're talking about
British political traditions we as
Americans find ourselves saying
look it's strange to us but it's old and
it uh and it works for them
and I think in the case of what we're
seeing here and this is not about the
who by the way I know there's good
discussion about who might be next and
what they might focus on what I think is
fascinating and important on both sides
of the Atlantic is the how
she was selected and this is a case
where how Prime Ministers are selected
um seems strange to my British friends
it is not old it is brand new 1998 and
it is I think demonstrably not working
and they're going to go through the
whole process again so let's talk about
then those those qualities as you say
recognized in the United States were
recognized the world over for the United
Kingdom stability and continuity have
they both been trashed and if they have
been is that temporary or can it return
pretty quickly
well I I think uh
Her Majesty the queen and and her life
and her example and the outflowing of
support following her passing is
actually something to focus on and I
think could teach us a lesson on both
sides of the Atlantic at this time
a word that that came up in almost every
tribute I read and I heard about her
life in her 70-year Reign was the word
steadfast
and appropriately and what I think is
interesting if you look at how she led
she was steadfast and she was always
open to change
because if you aren't open to change
then you become fixated and it doesn't
take too long before you look out of
touch and if you do the Other Extreme if
you get too far out in front then you
seem uh you know out of touch in the
other direction so the key is to always
be changing with public
opinion and I think that's something she
did and I think politicians on both
sides of the Atlantic
ought to learn from
and just finally Ambassador just uh
let's talk about Hard Cash there the the
mighty American corporate machine when
it's looking to invest I I know you know
many of the of the leaders of businesses
in the United States when they're
looking to invest in Europe are they now
beginning to put a question mark against
the United Kingdom because they're going
to wait for stability to return
I don't think so I think look I think
that the the
you went through brexit or going through
brexit that was
um something to get adjusted to for for
those of us on this side of the pond I
think look we've gone through our own
Democratic upheavals I don't know what
other diplomatic words to use I'm sure
British admirers of America have learned
more about the Electoral College
recently and all sorts of things we've
been going through and I think
what provides the stability in the
transatlantic relationship isn't who's
in 1600 Pennsylvania or who's in number
10 Downing Street I mean those are
important sometimes it's a deep deep
strong partnership it's always a good
friendship whether we agree or disagree
but the real strength and the real
ballast in the ship so to speak actually
comes from the millions of relationships
um across that Ocean between regular
citizens between you know we watch each
other's television we read each other's
books we watch each other's sport all of
that military leadership intelligence
cooperation the special relationship I
think lives in and through each and
every one of those sinews of peace to uh
paraphrase Winston Churchill
um Ambassador Matthew Basin very good
talking to you again thank you very much
indeed for joining us on Sky News once
again
U.S ambassador to the United Kingdom
well it was just after half past one
this afternoon that Liz trust stood on
the steps of Downing Street behind me
the same steps where just 44 days
earlier she pledged to deliver deliver
this time though she announced her
resignation and this is what she said
I came into office
at a time of great economic and
international instability
families and businesses were worried
about how to pay their bills
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine threatens
the security of our whole continent
and our country has been held back for
too long by low economic growth
I was elected by the conservative party
with a mandate to change this
we delivered on energy bills and on
cutting National Insurance
and we set out a vision for a low tax
high growth economy that would take
advantage of the freedoms of brexit
I recognize though
given the situation I cannot deliver the
Mandate on which I was elected by the
conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
this morning I met the chairman of the
1922 committee sir gray and Brady
we've agreed that there will be a
leadership election to be completed
within the next week
this will ensure that we remain on a
path to deliver our fiscal plans and
maintain our country's economic
stability and National Security
I will remain as prime minister until a
successor has been chosen thank you
a 92nd resignation speech of Liz trust
there well I'm joined Now by Aleister
Berta former conservative MP and former
foreign minister and Sarah Southern
David Cameron's former senior aide now
turned Tory comedian very good to talk
to you both well let's talk about first
of all Liz truss's decision to go only
44 days in power but Sarah Southern was
that too long should she have gone with
her original Chancellor
probably yes but perhaps you should
never have been selected in the first
place I was always quite surprised that
she got to the final two when it was the
leadership contest earlier in the summer
I felt that probably the party
membership would vote for us so it was a
shame that the MPS felt that she was the
right person to go up against Rishi
sunak but I think if you're going to
lose a Chancellor and the Home Secretary
in very short succession you haven't
really got a choice but to walk out of
that door at number 10 as well
okay Alistair about your thoughts on
that the damage that has been wreaked
and we care we all care most about the
country of course but also to your party
uh I obviously the the concern with the
country will be put right because uh
there'll be a reset that has to be a
reset of the economy many challenges are
still out there Chancellor Jeremy hands
has already started on that process but
the long-term damage is quite
considerable I mean the fact that we are
seen as a stable country a very stable
democracy we've been through all this we
will get through it it won't cause
terminal damage to the United Kingdom
but the damage to reputation is
significant damage to potential
investment is high so there's going to
be a an important challenge for the new
prime minister to put that right as soon
as possible and hope in the process that
some of the reputation of the party
which has been shredded in recent months
uh gets a chance to be restored along
with the reputation of the country
and that naturally leads us into who
should that be Sarah Southern what are
your thoughts and should there really be
another contest after that long drawn
out summer here we go another week and
seems at the moment that Uncle Tom
cobley and all are standing
well I'm really pleased that they've put
the threshold of 100 MPS because then
that at least is a big chunk of support
of the MPS and it's going to make sure
that the list is very small I would hope
that the MPS kind of unite behind one
candidate and we basically have a new
prime minister on Monday that will be my
preference I'm personally not that too
bothered whether the membership is asked
as to who should be the new prime
minister I think what we need to do now
is have a strong prime minister that is
totally supported by the members of
parliament what was Apparent at Party
Conference a mere what three and a half
weeks ago up in Birmingham is there was
no party discipline the MPS did not
support the Prime Minister you had
ministers who would you know literally
be openly criticizing the Prime Minister
which you would never have seen in the
past you would never have seen MPS you
know being that um unloyal disloyal
rather to the to the prime minister or
to the party leader I want to see the
conservative party rebuild so they can
actually deliver to the country as
that's what they haven't been doing
well I'm sure as the bird agrees but can
that actually happen I mean Sarah sudden
they're mentioning the the conference
and the shambles that that was and then
we had last night's vote where there's
pushing shoving I mean I mean it's the
political version of a of a bar brawl
taking place here do you think they can
sort it out
I hope so but I'm not sure there are
some really deep Rifts in the
conservative party
um I'm absolutely with Sarah we all hope
that colleagues would see that their
only possibility of recovering any
credibility with the British public is
to unite and present a a competent front
to the British people as they get on
with the job but I don't underestimate
how deep the divisions are uh they are
there between those who wanted to follow
a particular ideological economic path
who would be quite angry that it's not
come to pass there'll be those who felt
excluded uh by mistrust and indeed by
Boris Johnson and because of their views
in relation to the EU and will they be
able to come back and be part of the
team going forward those concerns are
still there uh there's splits sometimes
between those in different parts of the
country and what their needs are there's
some big challenges there so I don't
think we should I I think the
conservative party has got to address
these honestly not simply assume that
these differences will go away because
unless they do unless they are prepared
to recognize that we have moved on from
some of the problems in the past I think
some of the sharp differences will be
there and so Ella braverman's um
so-called resignation yesterday uh it
seemed to point the finger to where some
of those debates would go and that's
what we don't want to see because that
sort of sharp contest will really focus
on the divisions in the party which is
not probably what the company wants to
see either
and just the last thought about this
search for a big figure a uniting figure
a reassuring figure well Sarah Southern
they've already actually got one haven't
they who uh the resident of the the door
that I'm standing 20 meters away for
number 11 the chancellor and whoever
becomes prime minister has got a pretty
big character to work alongside
absolutely I think Jeremy Hunt probably
won't throw his hat into to the the ring
I think he is being a good Chancellor so
far
um I think Penny Morton would be an
excellent choice I would also support
Ben Wallace uh but whoever we pick Let's
unite let's just get on with the job uh
we haven't got long until there's a next
general election so let's put the front
front foot forward and support whoever
next goes into number 10. okay great
talking to you both thank you very much
indeed Sarah Southern and Aleister Bert
and you're watching Sky News Tonight
coming up I'm going to be speaking to
the snps Westminster leader he is of
course Ian Blackford
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
use Midlands correspondent based here in
Birmingham
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
we're getting more and more stabbings
and essentially I think it's more
younger children here in the diverse
Industrial
into heart of England we hear from
people who have real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
we have to be prepared that patients
will die from from this illness
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
fighting back to Downey street now the
first minister of Scotland Nicholas
sturgeon has also been reacting to the
prime minister's resignation this is
what she said
in terms of my interactions with lots of
trusts you know it is quite absurd I
guess that she has come into office and
left office and there hasn't even been a
phone call to me or to the first
minister of Wales but actually in the
you know the the Realms of political
history let's just is going to be a
footnote and you know we need to know
firstly see stability
for the UK um and that means undoubtedly
a general election to try to restore
some kind of stability
let's talk now then to the leader of the
SNP in Westminster Ian Blackford very
good to talk to you Mr Blackford and
just on that um from the first Minister
there there's clearly no love lost
between them
well no indeed
um and of course you had the first
minutes of scene there that you'd never
met uh Liz trust neither that myself has
better than the third party in
Westminster
mistrust as God and I'm I'm relieved
that we've had the announcement today
but let's just reflect on the Legacy
that she leaves behind because that
followed from the mini budget the
damaging impact that it had on the
financial markets the intervention of
the bank of England the increase in
mortgage rates that Legacy is that many
people are facing higher mortgage costs
as a as a consequence and revolves
although we've got the energy price cap
in place for a few months and I welcome
that we've still got the issue of what
happens next spring when that cat comes
off so there are specific challenges
that we Face we all have witnessed the
scenes yesterday in the House of Commons
the chaos that's gone on I think it is
the case that this is a conservative
government that's out of time it's lost
its way and it is right that we have
that election that it's not just 30 MPS
and 20 members that are casting a vote
who used to be our next prime minister
Not Elected on the voice of the people
but they would have that general
election then we have the opportunity
for the public to have their say and
we're able to
point that course as their way forward
and of course for us and Spotlight
opportunity to be able to express our
desire to have that to referendum and
Scotland's Future Okay well we've heard
that call we heard it from Nicholas
sturgeon of course we've heard it from
secure starmer it's a red Davey we hear
it from all the members of the
opposition but given the system how do
you get one and given the size of the
conservative majority
well that is the issue and I would
appeal to conservative MPS to recognize
the public mood that the public Are
Climbing for the election the support
for the conservative party has fallen
through the floor
we could limp on with the conservative
government right through to 2024 but I
would ask the question is that really in
the interest of all the nations of the
United Kingdom I think at some point
they've got to put the national
interests to the front and not just the
narrow party and just what you see is a
toy party that's split you've seen that
already emerging and needs to be instead
who should become the leader in many
respects some of the differences some of
the difficulties are really to do with
the post brexit period and that brexit
that has done enormous damage to the UK
to our trading capability to to jobs to
investment and perhaps that's often the
important aspects we should be
discussing about when we're considering
delivering sustainable electronomic
growth because many of the past and the
women are sustainable economic growth
have been constrained by brexit
and do you ever have any views on who
should become the next prime minister or
do you just think that's up to the
conservative party they're going to do
what they're going to do we want a
general election well they are going to
do what they want to do but of course we
can explore our differences
um I've been said to her as a government
that we've got to respect the right to
Scotland to have that Independence
referendum but I'll extend the hand of
friendship if I need to see that of
course we will work constructively where
we can and I know that will be true for
the first Ministers of the devolved
Nations as well there are times we have
to work together of course we Face many
challenges not least Ukraine warn there
are times where we do cool together
because it's right the whole of us
collectively stand with the people of
Ukraine we stand up against President
Putin and we have a demonstration of
that in the House of Commons today with
the statements from Ben Wallace so I
think there are times that we can work
together there but let's not
underestimate the the challenges and the
scale of differences that we have and I
think the anger that we have that the
costs that that are for many people from
the impact of Tony policies and let's
not forget whilst the chancellor has
deemed at the Tour de government to some
extent that they plugged the Gap by
removing the tax cuts there's that sword
that hangs over us called public
spending cuts that would do enormous
damage to individuals to families to
communities and we can't have a story
austerity 2.0 so there's going to be
some big challenges over the course of
the coming period
and just lastly a quick thought Mr
Blackford on the the prospect of Boris
Johnson standing and perhaps getting
back in here
good grief
Heaven's no I think would be my response
I you know
Potter Johnson was showing the door and
for very good reasons
um the behavior that we saw when he was
in office he simply wasn't fit for an
office
I think the public would really question
what the conservative party are up to if
there's any consideration of bringing
Boris Johnson back again that simply
cannot be allowed to happen for the sake
of all of us